grazie è un grande privilegio per me
essere portavoce della nostra scoperta
scientifica infatti abbiamo intercettato
per la prima volta un'onda
gravitazionale che attraversava la terra
ma in questo speech spero di potervi
dare un'idea dell'importanza di questo
risultato
tutto parte tutto parte ovviamente dall
esplorazione dell'universo
questa è la fotografia del cielo
stellato nell'emisfero australe la via
lattea domina il cielo stellato è
sicuramente è una meravigliosa
meravigliosa fotografia è stata
ispirazione ed è soprattutto in oggetto
di indagine da molto molto tempo
ecco ma nonostante tutti i nostri
progressi e tutta la nostra scienza
purtroppo ad oggi conosciamo soltanto un
ventesimo di ciò di cui è fatto
l'universo un 5 per cento abbastanza
insoddisfacente e la restante parte il
95 per cento
si tratta di materia oscura
sappiamo che esiste perché ne vediamo
l'attrazione gravitazionale sulla
materia che conosciamo però è materia
che non corrisponde a nessuna
caratteristica della materia che noi
conosciamo
si tratta di energia oscura è una
qualche forma di energia distribuita
nello spazio che è necessaria per
spiegare come mai
osserviamo che lo spazio stia
espandendosi in un'accelerazione
ecco questo potrebbe essere una
proprietà dello spazio vuoto che però
finora è sfuggito a nostra indagine
queste sono grandissime questioni ancora
aperte tutte da indagare
noi abbiamo allungato la nostra vista
sulla luce di universo costruendo un
meravigliosi telescopi sia a terra che
nello spazio quella piccola macchia
rossa nel ingrandimento è in particolare
la galassia più lontana mai osservata è
stata osservata marzo
è distante così distante che la luce
della sua immagine ha impiegato più di
13 miliardi di anni a raggiungere noi ci
ha regalato questa fotografia che è
stata praticamente scattata a 400
milioni di anni dopo il big bang
in un epoca in cui l'universo la molto
giovane e il re la giovanissima questa
galassia probabilmente un paio di
centinaia di milioni di anni per una
galassia è un tempo corto abbiamo esteso
la nostra capacità di osservazione oltre
la luce visibile a una vasta gamma di
frequenze dello spettro elettromagnetico
qui abbiamo varie mappe del cielo che
mostrano al cielo come si vede le onde
radio
il cielo come si vede nel microonde il
cielo come si vede nell'infrarosso e il
cielo come si vede nei raggi gamma
ciascuna di queste mappe porta
un'informazione particolare diversa
dalle altre
qualche caratteristica dell'universo che
si mostra in queste mappe in particolare
possiamo prendere per esempio la mappa
del cielo a microonde beh la mappa del
cile microonde è in realtà la
testimonianza del big bang maggiore che
noi abbiamo perché da lì possiamo capire
le proprietà della radiazione fossile
che è stata liberata a soli 380 mila
anni dopo il big bang
ma non ci siamo accontentati di questo
negli ultimi anni negli ultimi decenni
abbiamo costruito rivelatori anche per
catturare le particelle di origine cosmi
che colpivano alla terra qui abbiamo
solo due esempi abbiamo a sinistra un
edificio in antartide che all'infido di
controllo di un enorme rivelatore che in
realtà immerso nei ghiacci
dell'antartide un rivelatore che caccia
neutrini invece a destra abbiamo
un'immagine della
international space station la stazione
spaziale internazionale che fra gli
altri esperimenti ospita un rivelatore
per misurare la composizione dei raggi
cosmici di materia e antimateria nei
raggi cosmici
tuttavia tutto questo enorme sforzo non
era ancora abbastanza mancava un
tassello fondamentale perché è la
gravità che domina l'evoluzione
l'universo e la gravità che determina la
struttura dell'universo che conosciamo e
quindi ci serviva un senso un altro
sensore un sensore che fosse in grado di
trascinare hanno poi l'informazione sui
campi gravitazionali su come si
modificano in campo qualificazione di
lontano da noi
ebbene un ricevitore di onde
gravitazionali ora einstein un secolo fa
ci ha insegnato che la gravità domina il
tempo controlla il ritmo di ogni
fenomeno infatti possiamo immaginare per
esempio in uno spazio di essere
spettatori di un concerto lontano da una
grande massa quindi come se fosse una
stazione spaziale interplanetaria
diciamo così immaginiamo di ascoltare
questo del concerto di essere lì
presenti a questo per concerto
immaginiamo di confrontare questa
esperienza con un concerto gemello che
invece avviene se viene trasmesso da
vicino della grande massa ora quello che
succede che da questo confronto noi
ricaviamo che il concerto vicino la
grande massa viene rallentato dalla
gravità la grande massa rallenta il
tempo fra l'inter concerto come
qualunque fenomeno naturale è una legge
universale
stessa cosa sulle distanze sullo spazio
noi sappiamo che la gravità curva e
piega di traiettorie l'esperienza di
secoli siamo così però
ragionandoci su quello che succede che
einstein ci ha dimostrato che il modo
con cui la gravità piega di traiettorie
immaginiamo di lanciare da a primo obi
primo lo stesso oggetto che abbiamo
lanciato da bree da abi lontano da massa
la traiettoria è praticamente rettilinea
andiamo più vicini alla grande massa
quando lanciamo questo oggetto a
traiettoria si piega ecco il modo con
cui si piegano queste traiettorie
talmente universale che è possibile
descriverlo come una proprietà dello
spazio stesso come una variazione delle
distanze dello spazio e quindi possiamo
dire grazie einstein che è lo spazio che
si curva per la presenza delle masse per
la gravità ecco quindi possiamo dire che
la gravità forgia lo spazio tempo
determina la struttura dello spazio
tempo in cui viviamo
ecco ci sono voluti decenni però dopo
l'intuizione iniziale di einstein per
convincere la comunità dei fisici
teorici prima e poi tutti gli altri
scienziati che le sue predizioni abbiano
effettivamente molto bene fondate in
particolare aveva fatto due predizioni
estreme e la possibilità che ci potesse
essere una massa talmente concentrata da
impedire a qualunque cosa di uscire di
scappare di fuggire e questi li abbiamo
chiamati i buchi neri negli anni 60
quello che si vede questa superficie che
è ovviamente una visualizzazione di
artistica diciamo che è una superficie
scura perché niente può sfuggire da
quella superficie non neppure alla luce
noi in particolare perdiamo ogni
informazione che sia caduta dentro il
bottone buco nero
ecco un'altra grande predizione che
costò ne siamo così diversi decenni
prima di riuscire a essere condivisa su
quella delle onde gravitazionali in
pratica noi prendiamo immaginiamo a due
stelle due grandi masse che orbitano
molto velocemente una intorno all'altra
bene allora muovendosi così velocemente
il fremito che provocano alla curvatura
dello spazio in realtà è tale da poter
emettere un'onda non da una vibrazione
che si propaga con la velocità della
luce
allontanandosi dalla sorgente ora le
qualità di queste onde sono
particolarmente strane nel senso che
interagiscano così poco con quello che
trovano che praticamente sono
inarrestabili e ed è sicuramente un
linguaggio del cosmo che prima c'era
impedito di conoscere cosa succede
quando un'onda gravitazionale raggiunge
la terra
beh per fortuna siamo lontani da
sorgente quindi si può fare la
matematica un po più semplice ma in
realtà
immaginate quel tubo che vedete
immaginate le onde gravitazionali venga
attraverso l'asse del tubo beh non la
realizzazione deformando lo spazio
cambiando le distanze ovalizzata
continuamente il tubo e quindi deforma
qualunque corpo si è messo nello spazio
potremmo dire di forma lo spazio in un
modo che è direttamente proporzionale
alla distanza che stiamo osservando
quindi più salviamo in grande e più la
deformazione sarà grande
se osserviamo in piccolo alle formazioni
sarà piccola ecco questo effetto però è
estremamente minuscolo per questo il
problema lo spostamento è qualcosa come
dice la meno 18 metri su ogni chilometro
ecco non più grande di quello
ecco questo vuol dire che siamo a caccia
di misurare un miliardesimo di un
miliardesimo di metro e questa dalla
sfida costruire rivelatori e abbiamo
messo mezzo secolo per farlo che fossero
in grado di a di trovare un
uno spostamento di corpi che una
variazione distanza che affresco di
fondente a un miliardesimo della
dimensione di un auto su un chilometro
abbiamo avuto tanti tentativi che i
fisici hanno fatto negli anni io in
particolare ho dedicato la mia
giovinezza un rivelatore a padova che
qui rappresentato con i miei colleghi di
quel tempo
ecco questo rivelatore non ha portato
successo nel senso che non è riuscito ad
arrivare la sigla necessaria ma come
tutto in scienza un insuccesso rispetto
alla fine finale in realtà non è un
fruttuoso perché ti permette di partire
da una nuova base per costruire cose
nuove
la tecnologia che si è rivelata vincente
invece è stata sviluppata diciamo così
negli anni 90 ed è quella basata su gli
interferometri un rivelatore che
praticamente fatto di luce di luce di
specchi quindi come funziona c'è una
luce laser molto ampia che viene sparata
dentro un fascio in divisa in due fasi
un fascio va a colpire uno specchio
faceva colpire altro specchio è
praticamente un sistema telemetria ci
misuriamo la distanza di questi specchi
distanti ecco come misuriamo
semplicemente guardando la luce che
torna indietro
ecco questo è il rivelatore virgo
costruito fra pisa e pontedera una
collaborazione internazionale
ecco che ha già funzionato e che adesso
in fase di finale di upgrade giovedì
miglioramento nella sua sensibilità è
fatto di queste specchi a tre chilometri
di distanza al fondo a quelle due bracci
a 90 gradi che potete vedere dalla foto
cosa c'è dentro questi lunghi e cunicoli
azzurri beh c'è quello che vi ho
mostrato in cima alla foto qui un tubo
un tubo pieno di cose di vuoto noi
vogliamo che in quel tubo ci sia solo la
luce possibilmente nient'altro per non
disturbare la misura poi la luce arriva
in fondo ai 3 km e rimbalza su specchi
che sono invece nella figura al centro
in basso epson specchi molto grandi
estremamente sofisticati ecco questi
specchi sono in un certo senso molto
complicati da costruire e sono collegati
a un sistema molto complesso perché
devono essere trascinati dall'onda
gravitazionale ma non disturbati dagli
effetti grossi di vibrazioni del terreno
e acustica eccetera eccetera che
l'attività umana porta poi nei suoi nel
suo svolgersi diciamo così ecco quindi
se non ha un sacco di tecnologia in
questa in questi rivelatori ma un
relatore non basta ci vuole una
collaborazione internazionale qui è un
punto cruciale cioè ogni rivelatore a un
suo rumore il rumore non riesci anno in
questo rumore non riesce a distinguere
caratteri distintivi di un qualcosa che
viene dal cosmo per poter riuscire a
distinguere che qualcosa dal cosmo
entrato nei tuoi rivelatori devi poterlo
vedere consistentemente in più siti in
più osservatori e quindi è stata
costruita una rete internazionale
siamo migliaia di scienziati grossomodo
e in particolare i due rivelatori
americani live and for the livingston
erano operativi il settembre scorso
mentre virgo è ancora in fase di
miglioramento delle sue prestazioni
ecco cosa successe di magico quel
settembre il 14 settembre
beh è la notte per fortuna
questi complessi rivelatori erano ancora
in una fase di messa a punto era come un
enorme organo che dovesse essere
accordato
prima del concerto no il concerto era
previsto per qualche giorno dopo
per fortuna era notte e gli elettori
americani stavano funzionando senza
essere disturbati dalle dalle nostre
test di verifica e l'onda arriva e
colpisce prima livingston danno un
piccolo segnale pochi cicli pochi cicli
su e giù è uscita dal rivelatore
notate che la durata di questo segnale
poco più di un decimo di secondo
ma silva e dopo 7 millisecondi
l'onda colpisce hanford e mostra nel
rivelatore è una forma molto analoga
infatti la cosa fondamentale che ci
riempie anche di gioia che il nostro
programma automatico di riconoscimento
di segnali ha capito capì subito in tre
minuti che si trattava di un segnale
consistente qualcosa che difficilmente
si poteva spiegare con un disturbo nei
singoli rivelatori e quindi subito la
domanda è questa la prima silva seconda
gravitazionale beh parti subito
un'attività frenetica e che durò cinque
mesi prima di tutto
lanciamo l'allarme in modo da poter dire
per favore non continuate la cordata
degli strumenti così com'è va bene
dobbiamo studiare come stanno
funzionando in questo momento per non
disturbare le loro caratteristiche
secondo abbiamo mandato un allarme ai
partner astronomici perché si è visto un
organizzazione le devi cercare se c'è
una sorgente elettromagnetica per
esempio che si è accesa
contemporaneamente nel cielo
ma la cosa più difficile per noi sono
stati cinque mesi di verifiche modifiche
molto meticoloso che abbiamo affrontato
per poter essere sicuri e poter
difendere la nostra affermazione di aver
visto per la prima volta un evento
cosmico raggiungere la terra ecco sono
state verifica mente colori abbiamo
dovuto escludere un sacco di possibilità
e sono state verifiche che sono state
svolte in un clima di riservatezza noi
non abbiamo comunicato al mondo esterno
nostra scoperta se non il 11 febbraio
cinque mesi dopo
questo perché è perché ci vuole libertà
libertà di critica ci vuole confronto
confronto aspro duro di idee non di
personalità
per riuscire a fare un buon lavoro
scientifico e quindi la collaborazione
si è chiusa e ha cominciato a discutere
noi facciamo la parte dell'avvocato
difensore e un sacco di gente piace la
parte l'avvocato del diavolo di per
uccidere il segnale ma alla fine il
segnale è diventato effettivamente
indistruttibile e dopo un secolo di
sviluppo teorico il mezzo secolo di
sviluppo strumentale finalmente abbiamo
un interpretazione della prima sillaba
di questo linguaggio onda gravitazionale
che raggiunge la terra si trattava di
l'ultima danza all'ultimo giro di orbita
di due buchi neri due buchi neri grossi
30 volte grosso modo alla massa del
nostro sole
ecco che orbitando perdono l'ultima
energia a disposizione e poi si fondono
con l'it non si fondono in un unico buco
nero finale ecco una sessantina di volte
la massa del nostro sole
beh questi oggetti sono molto piccoli
sono grosso modo un centinaio di
chilometri di raggio diciamo quindi sono
una grande massa in poco spazio
ecco la scoperta è rivoluzionaria la
rivoluzionaria per tre motivi
fondamentali 1 perché è la prima
registrazione diretta di buchi neri cioè
prima non potevamo osservare i buchi
neri direttamente perché il buco nero
non si può vedere niente esce il buco
nero tranne la vibrazione lo spazio
tempo che il suo orizzonte degli eventi
che il suo bordeaux crea
diciamo quindi questo è il primo
messaggio quindi si prima di eravamo
convinti dell'esistenza infine
rivedevamo la materia a cadere dentro
una zona molto piccola dello spazio beh
questa è una osservazione diretta è
molto diverso più importanti e poi
questo è stato l'evento più violento che
abbiamo mai registrato in astrofisica
pensate che ben tre ma se solari sono
state convertite in energia in un decimo
di secondo
questo è un evento di estrema violenza
l'ultima
cosa ma molto importante che questo
adatta la conferma che la teoria che
usiamo per interpretare questo
linguaggio che è stata sviluppata sulla
base della teoria di einstein è ancora
valida effettivamente funziona anche in
questo regime in cui nessun fisico
nessun astronomo aveva mai provata prima
e quindi è un buon passo di partenza per
un futuro perché possiamo effettivamente
decifrare i futuri messaggi che ci
arrivano sulla base delle competenze di
linguaggio che abbiamo acquisito nei
decenni passati
questa è un'immagine simulata di quello
che una persona poteva vedere se fosse
si fosse trovata affitto la distanza
dalla coppia di buchi neri che stanno
facendo l'ultimo giro di danza
ecco quello che vedete è un campo
stellato dietro ai buchi neri perché
campo stellato si muove sia agita
seguendo il motto dei buchi neri
essenzialmente perché la gravità piega
traiettorie della luce che vengono dalle
stelle che sono in realtà fisse ferme
dietro questi due buchi neri ecco questo
è un evento molto importante ma
soprattutto è un po più vento
incoronamento in un sacco di lavoro ma è
soprattutto l'alba di una nuova
esplorazione dell'universo è un qualcosa
di molto importante dal punto di vista
della nostra sete di conoscenza è
effettivamente un passaggio importante
per capire meglio cos'è la gravità cos'è
lo spazio cosa il tempo potrebbe essere
una chiave per quello che alcuni
chiamano teoria del tutto ma soprattutto
io penso che abbiamo creato usando la
metafora per gli spicci precedenti un
campo base
un nuovo campo base da cui partire per
l'esplorazione su scienza e tecnologia
che non possiamo neanche immaginare
io oggi non sono abbastanza saggio per
poter intuire che tipo di svolte e di
applicazioni in scienza e tecnologia
potranno nascere da questa cosa
nella mia generazione forse la mia
generazione non vedrà il vero frutto
di questo lavoro ma mai per questo che
noi lavoriamo non per noi per le
generazioni future
e questo il messaggio che dobbiamo dare
come scienziati quindi adesso cose che
sono patrimonio diciamo così della
fantascienza dell'immaginazione in un
futuro potrebbero essere effettivamente
qualcosa di verificabile qualcosa di
utilizzabile
un futuro che potrebbe essere lontano
grazie